The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We have
the privilege today
of hearing from
Professor Susan Silbey.
Professor Silbey
taught this class
with Professor [? Dysart ?]
and me in the last two years.
And she is a sociologist,
political scientist,
anthropologist, head of
the anthropology section.
And obviously brings a
different perspective
to a number of these issues than
I, a poor country economist do.
And as I said last
time, I showed
you a little bit of the
economics of energy demand,
and then suggested at
the end of the lecture,
by talking about
dollars on the sidewalk
and what picked up in energy
efficiency on the one hand,
and people aggressively
investing in energy
efficiency on the other hand.
Perhaps, the notion of
tangible energy services
wasn't quite rich enough
to explain energy demand.
And now, it will
all be explained.
SUSAN SILBEY: Well, Hello,
it's rather a tall order.
But we'll try.
On Monday, Dick talked to
you about the economics
of energy demand.
He talked about how
demand for energy
is derived from demand
for products and services.
And so we talk
about it as mediated
or derived demand, which
requires some adjustments
in the basic economic models.
He also mentioned, I
believe, that variations
in derived demand depend upon
fixed capital investments, as
well as short and
long run expectations.
And that, because of those
short and long run expectations,
income and price
elasticities are generally
limited, unlike in other
products and services,
and thus, constraining
the ability
to maximize with
efficient responses.
And as Dick just
mentioned again,
people do not always maximize
or optimize, let me say,
their decisions.
There's lots of
possible efficiencies
that are not pursued.
And he mentioned, I believe,
on Monday, the leaving
those dollars on the sidewalk.
Because of, perhaps,
imperfect information,
riskiness and uncertainty
of future savings,
could be a lot of
other reasons too.
And as he mentioned
again, just now,
people might be over investing.
Now, let's think
about what that means.
To over invest in efficiency
means, by economic models,
you're not going to get
a specific dollar return,
the Prius being example.
But there might be other
reasons why people might do it.
That is go for more efficiency
than is defined economically.
So why do we see economically
non-optimal decisions?
That's the $64,000 question.
How do people act?
Why do people do what they do?
Why are they not, in
the economic model,
perfectly rational actors?
Now, it is the mission
of all of social science
to try to describe
human behavior.
But the explanations
that come from economics
are not necessarily
the same that come
from the other social sciences.
How many of you have had
a course in economics
before this one?
Oh, lots of you, because it's
required for this course.
That's right.
But I didn't see every hand.
I was wondering how accurate
this survey was going to be.
How many of you have had
a political science class?
Let me see those hands.
I can't see, one, two,
three, four, five, six.
How many-- oh did I
miss some over here?
Seven, eight.
OK, how many have
had a history class?
Wow, that's pretty good.
How many have had an
anthropology class?
Zero, right?
Oh, one, two.
And we don't offer sociology
here for undergraduates, only
really for graduate students.
So this-- why do
people do what they do?
It turns out that each
of the social sciences
has a slightly different answer.
And so by way of, well,
for those of you who
have had a political
science class, how is it
different from economics?
Nobody wants-- Yeah, Andrew?
AUDIENCE: No, equations
and stuff like that.
SUSAN SILBEY: Well, that
turns out not to be true.
It just isn't in the--
it's just not in the
undergraduate class.
There are plenty of equations.
There are plenty of
equations in sociology, too,
not in anthropology.
OK, so maybe I need to do this.
So if you think of
the social sciences
as the study of human behavior,
there is a division of labor.
Now, this division of labor
can be simply explained,
but gets a little complicated
when you go into detail.
So we might think of the
most basic and simplest
social science as
psychology, which we almost
don't have anymore,
which is about
what goes on inside
people's heads.
Psychology being the
study of a person,
and explaining what this
person does by looking inside.
And we have various terms for
talking about what's inside
people's heads, their desires,
we talk about the id, which
is the desires you have, and
the ego, which is the control,
and the notion of a
constraint on what you do.
But then we have--
and I would put psychology
by itself as different
from the rest of
the social sciences.
And then we have
sociology, which
says that it is
interested in what
goes on between two or more
persons, never a person alone.
And the unit of analysis, or
the subject, is the interaction.
Not what's in here,
but what is exchanged
between the two of them.
Now, some people would
say that sociology
is the queen, because
everything follows
from these interactions.
Because the interactions
can take various patterns.
So they can be interactions
about production
and distribution.
And then we get economics.
If you can think about
it as the interactions
where some people
are making things
that other people are receiving.
And it happens through this
thing called the market.
Which is sort of an
invisible black box.
Then we might have
interactions that have
to do with force, violence.
And when that's
concentrated, we call
that the state who has
a monopoly of force.
And that's what political
science studies.
So here, we have
four social sciences
leaving the study of the
circulation of the signs.
This one's more complicated.
That's probably
why only two of you
took the classes, because you
don't understand what it is.
But it's the circulation of the
signs and symbols among people.
And we call that culture.
And that's what
anthropology studies,
the practices, and
the production,
and circulation of signs.
So there you have
the social sciences.
Now, that's a very
simple, easy distinction.
But like most things in
life, that's too simple.
And in any place--
oh, I forgot, you're
not supposed to.
Oh, I forgot, I
forgot, I forgot.
No human power here.
OK, so we have
political science, which
studies force and the state.
But it overlaps
with some sociology,
which looks at the
patterns of interactions.
And there's something
called political sociology.
And then some of sociology
studies production
and distribution.
And we call that
economic sociology.
And some of economics
is now interested in how
people's desires and behaviors
affect their decision making.
We call that
behavioral economics.
And that overlaps with
psychology and anthropology.
So you might just
think about what
is actually studied as having
normal distributions that
overlap.
And depending--
lots of people are
studying in these places, which
we call interdisciplinary.
And that's how you
get a class like this.
OK, so why do people,
or how do people--
how do people deal with
these questions about energy?
How do they make the decisions?
So what I'm going to try to do
today, and this is my outline,
is to go through
some basic models,
some very general models, about
how people make decisions,
the variations and the
motives, we might say,
or the vocabularies of motive.
I'm going to look
at some results
from cognitive science and
sociology of decision making,
going to look at
a few experiments.
And then, maybe, we can
end, if time permits,
with some discussion
of what happens
when we focus on the
individual and the ironies
of popular psychology.
I'm not sure we'll get there.
In future classes,
I know you are
going to discuss
decision making in firms
and organizations, which
are aggregates, patterned
aggregates.
Not one, but the pattern
by which people are
arranged in their activities.
Those are organizations
and firms.
And we will look at
states, or you will,
in which we make
public policies.
So how do people make decisions?
How do we make decisions
about right and wrong?
What kind of car to buy?
Why are people buying that
Prius even though they'll never
recoup the savings?
Why do we think that skinny
women are beautiful now?
And 100 years ago, we
thought that heavy women
were beautiful?
Maybe none of you know
that that was the case?
AUDIENCE: Advertising.
SUSAN SILBEY: OK, advertising.
Why might that-- but what
about the advertising?
What did the advertising say?
And was it advertising
100 years ago?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's
some predominately--
fashion advertising
of the '50s and '60s
switched from more
volumptuous sexual icon
to something really skinny.
There's one person
in particular named
Twiggy who kind of became a
very famous, very skinny fashion
model.
And everyhting from
that kind of followed.
SUSAN SILBEY: Yeah, but it
was in the 19th century,
before there was advertising.
Yes, David.
AUDIENCE: I'd say there's
also a change in the signaling
about what you're buying.
If you go further
back, there are
depictions of larger, heavier
people as being wealthy,
which is something [INAUDIBLE].
Which was, you didn't
have to work in fields.
You had enough to eat.
[INAUDIBLE]
SUSAN SILBEY: That's right.
And the signaling was,
in the 19th century,
to have heft on you meant
you were wealthy enough
to eat well.
Because most people did not.
So this is just a
little exercise.
And this is about culture.
This is about the circulating
signs, the signaling.
So you've all got it.
You got it.
The culture encourages
us to want certain things
to think their beautiful.
Is there anything else?
None of you believe--
AUDIENCE: Education as well.
SUSAN SILBEY: You're all so
socialized, it's fantastic.
AUDIENCE: If we put that
slide we had up on Monday
that showed you that you're not
going to make your money back
from buying Prius, I think
that would deter people
from buying them.
And similarly with things
like obesity in the US,
while being as skinny as
Twiggy might not be healthy,
generally, more fit
would be more healthy
due to the knowledge we
have now we might not
have had 100 years ago.
SUSAN SILBEY: That's
right, that's right.
You've got it.
But there's another set of
reasons people often offer.
I'll go back.
Well, you know
the other reasons?
None of you have any other
reasons why we do what we do?
Yeah, is that Matthew?
AUDIENCE: They saw other
people doing the same thing.
[INAUDIBLE]
SUSAN SILBEY: These are
all sociological and
anthropological reasons.
And I just love it, as being
head of that department.
But I usually get, not
necessarily in this class,
I think you've all
learned quite well,
many students tell me
that they are programmed
to want and do certain things.
And I'm so surprised
MIT students
not coming up with that.
Because when I teach sociology
or anthropology class,
this is the one
that comes up first.
None of you believe
that, anymore?
It's not in your DNA.
Fantastic, I love it.
I love it.
I think it's great.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I mean, there's
evolutionary psychologists
who would argue that we're
attracted to certain things
based on reproductive purposes.
AUDIENCE: But not a Prius.
[INAUDIBLE] the hourglass shape.
Wider hips.
[INAUDIBLE]
SUSAN SILBEY: I should have
worn something different.
OK, all right, so what I want to
offer before we go further is.
Oh, did you have
your hand up, David?
AUDIENCE: I was going to say,
you posed the question why
did the appeal change from women
that were rounder to women that
were skinnier?
SUSAN SILBEY: Except
for their boobs.
AUDIENCE: So DNA
kind doesn't account
for that, because your
DNA didn't change over
the course of 50
years or 100 years.
But maybe it is hardcoded
DNA is that [INAUDIBLE]
or able to support themselves,
raise children, or whatever.
So maybe the ideal, what
it is in the social,
this woman is fit.
So that means that
she's more capable?
SUSAN SILBEY: So
maybe it's fit versus
the specific definition of fit.
AUDIENCE: Exactly, yeah so
part of it comes from the DNA
that you're seeking.
But the social kind of
defines what exactly--
SUSAN SILBEY: That means.
Well, that's a very
interesting observation.
Because there's lots
of good social theory
which suggests that
about lots of concepts.
That many-- all
societies have some form
of marriage system and family
system for raising children.
So you might say that there is
a human system of reproduction
in the social relations, in
addition to the biological.
But, so we say there
is something called
the institution of the family.
But that varies from
society to society.
And that's the same kind--
the specificity varies.
Though there could be
something more general.
And that's a good
introduction to what
I want to do for a few minutes.
Is I want to suggest to you that
there are a few general models
of human action, which I sort
of suggested in the differences
among the social sciences.
And we use different
concepts and terminology
to describe what is
observable in human behavior.
And these social
science theories
are not always, as Andrew
suggested at the outset,
quantified into equations.
That economics begins and
ends with those equations.
The other social
sciences haven't all
developed into equations
for most of what they do.
But you will find it in some.
In all of them,
there'll be some.
So I want to show
you, for example,
the equation you had on Monday.
That's an economic one
about derived demand.
Well, here's one you all
you may or may not know.
This is one of my favorite ones.
Because it's the field
that I'm specialist in.
And it says that formal social
control is inversely related
to informal social control.
Social control is what we do to
manage other people's behavior,
or to manage behavior.
And formal social control
simply means government.
And informal means
everything that's
not the government, that's not
the legitimate use of force.
And the more you have
of informal norms,
informal culture, the less
you have of government.
That's what this theory says.
So one varies inversely.
And sociologists
have been trying
to validate this
theory for a long time.
OK, theories without
equations are an organization
of words that are
clearly defined,
that try to make
explicit what is often
tacit, that is unspoken.
And in social
science, our task is
to make explicit and
describable through systematic
observations, through
transparent methods, what
goes on in human behavior.
So Andrew's first answer to
me was more methodological
than it was conceptual.
And what I offered
in my distinctions
in the social science
was more conceptual.
The methods we use turn
out to be almost the same
across all the social sciences.
We observe, we ask, we count.
There are a variety
of ways of doing that.
OK, so how do people
make decisions?
Well, I tired to get from you
two different notions, more
cultural and institutional
versus biological.
But even if you look in the
non-biological explanations,
there are sort of patterns that
come up in the explanations
that people give.
So one pattern is the
psychological one,
that people act on the basis
of individual desires, wills.
That sometimes, this
individual desire and will
is a product of
their DNA, nature,
they made their biography,
their parenthood.
This is what made
them who there.
There are different
kinds of persons.
So this is the biological,
individualistic, personality,
psychology,
evolutionary biology.
Man makes history.
We have an Obama as
president because he's
a unique individual.
We had George Washington
because he was a special person.
Oh, Gandhi was charismatic.
These are the
explanations that say
there is something
about the person that
produces the behavior
and the achievements.
The alternative-- and
so, OK, so they're
unique and independent
individuals.
And society is merely the
aggregate of these individuals.
The philosophers and writers
who exemplify this point of view
include John Locke
in the 17th century,
John Stuart Mill in the 19th
century, Friedrich Hayek
and Milton Friedman
in the 20th century.
OK, when you come
across these names,
you can now put
them in the box that
says we can explain what
happens in the world, including
the production and
distribution of energy
by looking at
individual behavior.
And that's what we're
going to do today.
But there's a second answer,
or a second kind theory,
which many of you
gave me to start with,
which is that the motives and
the intentions of individuals
are located in a
larger circulation,
whether it's advertising
or education,
that people anticipate
certain things to happen.
That they locate
themselves in a sequence.
And so that it's
not the individual,
but it's what the
individual has learned
over time, and the experiences
that they have had,
and what the philosopher John
Dewey called situated action.
That an action
doesn't mean the same
in one place as in another.
And so therefore, the
action you make or do
isn't the same in
one place or another.
And if you take account
of that variation,
then it isn't the
individual causation.
But it's also the situation.
And the authors who say
these kinds of things
include Pierre Bourdieu.
And he calls this situation,
or these culturally
learned behaviors,
habits, or the habitus.
And Adam Smith, in his Theory
of Moral Sentiments, which
he wrote before he wrote The
Wealth of Nations in 1776,
do you all know The Wealth
of Nations, 1776, OK,
and you all know about
the invisible hand.
OK, yes, no?
Well, look it up on Wikipedia.
But what is important about that
theory, which most people take
as obvious, because the
foundation of the market
is that before he wrote
The Wealth of Nations he,
wrote The Theory of
Moral Sentiments.
And in that book,
what Adam Smith said
is that the person all
people will try to be good.
They will be limited
in their desires, which
is what gets translated
into demand in the market
by the expectation of what their
neighbors will think of them.
That doesn't hold very
true in the modern world,
except if you go
to what some of you
start at the
beginning, advertising,
and signaling, and education.
So what we desire,
Adam Smith said,
will be constrained
by what we think
our neighbors will think of us.
And that's the framework in
which our desires or demands
can shape a market.
So in this second
bifurcated notion,
it's not that history
makes the man.
It's that man makes history.
No, no, I said it backwards.
Erase that.
The second theory,
history makes the man.
So Barack Obama can
get elected in 2008.
He could not have gotten elected
president in 1980, or 1990,
or 2000.
Conditions had to be such,
is how the story would go.
Or that George Washington
would have been a farmer,
and he would have spent
his whole life as a farmer,
were it not for the
American Revolution,
which he did not participate
in until the war started.
He was not one of the
signers of the Declaration
of Independence.
They needed someone
to be a general.
Without that need, he wouldn't
have been the president.
And so this second model is
that personhood, identity, will,
the desires are produced and are
contingent on the opportunities
that exist, and the constraints.
And the authors who write
from this perspective
are Max Weber, Emile
[? Durkheim ?] Karl
Polanyi, Karl Marx,
Jean-Jacques Rousseau.
So when you encounter
those names,
you can put them as antithesis
to Locke, Mill, Hayek,
and Friedman.
OK, now, I'll put in
a little amendment
that's not in the notes.
That for the most
part, Americans,
when you survey
them and ask them
why things happen as they do,
they give you the first answer.
Because people are special.
That's why what they have.
Or that's why things turn
out the way they are.
We are, in the United States,
a nation of individualists.
We rarely see the
patterns of aggregation.
So now, one more, one more
how do people make decisions.
There's one more
model that I'd like
to present to you, that's
not a binary model.
These have been binaries, right?
Two different views, individual,
biological, collective
and culture.
The sociologist Max
Weber offered us
a more complex notion.
He suggested that
action is social
whenever we take account
of somebody else,
just like Adam Smith's
notion of the moral person.
We care what our
neighbors think.
Now, Weber didn't say we care
what our neighbors think.
He merely said that he will
define action as social when
we take account of another,
when there's more than one.
And we anticipate,
or we care, or we
want to say something
about or imagine an other
in relationship to ourselves.
That's what makes it social.
So whenever you hear
the word "social,"
which is bandied about
something terrible,
it always means an
interaction of two or more.
And in his grand theory, which
I'll try to do in five minutes,
this is 1,000 pages, OK, you're
getting it in five minutes,
there are four ways
in which we can
take account of other people.
The first one is what he
called rational action.
And here, we have exactly
the economic model.
That people act
and make decisions
on the basis of reasoning,
of means and ends reasoning.
That they take account of the
objects in the external world,
the situations.
They mobilize logic.
And they try to figure out
how to get from here to there.
They maximize their ends by
figuring out appropriate means.
This is our economic
rational actor model.
And he called that
formal rational action.
But he said there was
another kind of rationality,
in which we were oriented
not to maximizing
means ends efficiencies, but
because there was something
we thought was good,
an absolute value.
This could be a conscious
belief in a God, who tells us
what to do.
It could be some ethical value,
such as do unto others as you
would have them do unto you.
It could be aesthetic
to maximize beauty.
It could be to
maximize equality,
as communism was originally
imagined by Karl Marx.
So that behavior is organized
to maximize or to fulfill
that absolute value.
It's not an efficiency
or logical requirement
of means and ends.
And the third kind of behavior--
so this is virtue.
Could be you want to be
environmentally sustainable,
whether it's efficient or not.
OK, that's an alternative
to efficiency.
The third kind of
behavior he described
was ones which come from our
feelings, from our emotions.
We do things because
it feels good.
Now, you all know
what that's like you
do a lot of that we all do.
That's why people take
drugs, drink alcohol,
have sex, because it feels good.
It's also the basis
on which we sometimes
convey honor to people.
We say some people are
better than others.
Being seen and celebrity,
this whole TV and internet
world of being there,
people are getting some sort
of emotional satisfaction.
And the fourth kind
of social action
is simply tradition and habit.
We act because we have
always done it this way.
And that, sometimes, is a little
bit of mimicry, but mimicry
of the past, rather than
necessarily something
co-present.
And there are lots of
societies, lots of groups.
And this institution,
MIT, is frequently
accused of being
stuck in its ways.
So when we were accredited a
few years ago, or re-accredited,
the re-accreditation
committee said
that MIT had just about come
into the 20th century in terms
of the information systems
in which it managed.
We had hardly made it to
the end of the 20th century,
because we don't change
things too easily.
OK, habit, it's comfortable.
So now, like those overlapping
disciplines, those overlapping
disciplines, all these
concepts have fuzzy borders.
So it's rare that you'll ever
find an empirically observable
action social action that's
just one kind, that's just
rational action, or that's
just affect without habit,
or something else.
And that brings us to exactly
where Dick left off on Monday.
What else, besides
rational action,
besides economic reasoning might
be affecting demand for energy?
OK, so these are the
basic models of--
and habit, or
past, is what those
are historic investments are
that we can't change very much.
That we have suburbs
and automobiles.
That we have
habituated preferences
in our political system
and the individualism
that makes it very hard for us
to change our energy production
and consumption systems.
So what I want-- this
is the big picture,
and now, let's look at some
specific research that wants
to do something with this.
But I would like you to take
away from this the notion
that any human action
involves usually
a combination of
these forms of action.
These are the
categories which we
mix and match to describe it.
So cognitive science
and the sociology
of decisions, these days
there's been a recent marriage.
And it may, in the end, end up
being a marriage of our brain
structure and our behavior.
So what used to be
psychology, asking people
why they do what they do,
watching them in experiments,
treating them just like
rats in experiments,
we now look inside their
brains with PET scans, fMRIs.
The neuroscientists look at
the brains, the architecture
of our brains, the
arrangement of the pieces,
that's about all
they can do, so far.
And look at the physical
matter inside our skulls,
where the psychologist used to
study, we might say, the mind.
Brain scientists
or neuroscientists
study the brain.
And the cognitive scientists
go, try to put the two together.
Is that fair?
Do we have any BCS majors here?
Not a one?
Not one brain and
cognitive science major.
Interesting, I
would have thought
you'd all want to
become brain scientists.
That's the future, folks.
Well, do the brain and cognitive
science of energy decisions.
There you go, there's
a dissertation for you.
OK, so some of this
marriage of mind and brain
has produced some
interesting results.
So that what people used
to think was hard wired,
the neuroscientists have
showed us is quite malleable.
That in fact, oh, I think up
until about the 1980s, doctors
and scientists would
say oh, well, you
might be able to regenerate
muscles if you've
had an accident or damaged it.
But the brain was what it
was and it never changed.
Well, we know that's not true.
Used to think it was
fixed and formed.
But now, we know that
the neurons are always
in the making.
And those circuits are changing.
The neurons and networks,
we have learned,
develop in response to
experience to the inputs.
So that they shape
the capacity to act.
So that it's not
just how you're born.
But the experiences
that you have had
transform your
mental capacities.
Well, you all know that's true.
You wouldn't have
gotten to MIT otherwise.
Unless you all think there
was all these equations
were in there to start with and
they just came out recently.
That you've learned.
You've learned how to
defer gratification.
That's what most successful
college students, to get here,
you learned.
And some people don't have the
experiences which allow that.
What if you're a
child who's never
had gratification of any
bodily or emotional function?
Well then delaying
it is not something
you could learn that
will be rewarded.
You understand what I'm saying?
So if you've never had a
full belly, then when food
is put in front of you,
you're not necessarily
going to wait to eat it
until you're told to eat it.
It's as simple as that.
And the same thing with
cognitive activities.
So there's lots
of work now going
on that is closing
the gap between what
is observable between the inner
states and the external aspects
of culture.
So in this work, in
this scholarship,
scholars, researchers,
have started
to distinguish a fundamental
difference between what
they call automatic cognition
and deliberate cognition.
Automatic cognition is rapid,
effortless, unintentional
thoughts, things which are
those habits, those things we
do without thinking.
And it allows quick
processing of information
without extended thought
or figuring out what to do.
Deliberate cognition is
slow, considered, measured.
Where we can reject or
accept alternatives.
We can consider various
actions to take.
Where we might actively
search for solutions,
for characteristics,
for connections,
for seeing if we can
find relationships.
And where we don't assume,
but we solve, you might say.
So examples of
automatic cognition
are as the example,
male and female.
We look at somebody and we
categorize them like that.
When we can't categorize them
like that, we start to think.
And we frequently, then,
refer to that person
as not usual or not normal.
Age, race, in the
United States is
a fundamental
automatic cognition.
Turns out not to be
that in all cultures.
In many cultures,
it's much more varied.
It's not a binary, like it
is in the United States.
So our habits are examples
of automatic cognition.
It's outside of our
thinking process.
It's outside of consciousness.
And it happens more often
when we're under stress.
The experiments put people
in different conditions.
And how quickly they respond
when they're under stress
is measurable.
In deliberate
cognition, what has
been shown is that people
deliberate and they think
about alternatives
when there has been
a disruption of those
habits, a disruption
of non-thinking-- of
acting without thought.
OK, so I want to give you
some empirical examples
of how this works.
The first example
is by Carol Heimer
at Northwestern
University, where
she did a study of neonatal
care in several hospitals.
She noticed in these
wards for preemie babies
that routines the
hospital had established
were used to manage
what was a very
uncertain medical
situation, very
uncertain for the
families, very stressful.
And that there was a very marked
hierarchy among the staff.
The aides at the bottom,
the doctors at the top,
the surgical nurses higher
up, others lower down.
And along with this
hierarchy of persons,
Heimer also identified
a continuum of routines.
At one end of her
spectrum, there
were tasks which were
highly routinized.
That there was almost never any
variation for how it was done.
And then there were
other tasks which
varied a lot from patient to
patient and family to family.
She noticed that when
there was either very, very
routinized or very,
very unroutinized,
that there was
deliberate cognition.
There was a great deal of talk,
examination, consideration
of alternatives.
But where there was
moderate routinization,
that things were automatic.
According to Heimer
the overroutinization
triggers deliberate
cognition, because people
are so overwhelmed and
overloaded with routines
that the things they have to
do routinely become a burden.
They become noise,
rather than a signal.
And they cease to focus
attention on the child
or on the situation.
Then because there's so many
things that need to be done,
and need to be done
in a specified way,
they have to think
about how to do it.
In underroutinized
context, they have
to figure out what to do
when there are no routines.
And they have to be inductive.
Is this like one we saw before?
Is this like the four
other cases last week?
So that lots and
lots of routine,
they have to think
about how to manage.
No routine, they have to think.
But simple, not high volume
of routines, and they
act without thought.
So that might be taking blood.
It might be putting
in the injection.
But if they have to do 10
of those things at once,
then they will think about it.
So that's one example.
In a second study about
residents in an Argentinean
shanty town, two scholars,
Auyero and Swistun
studied the ways in which
people handled uncertainty
in risk and especially the
conditions under which--
the conditions which
sustained uncertainty
and sometimes led to assessments
of environmental pollutants.
So they saw that sometimes,
people paid attention
to the pollutants around them.
And sometimes, they didn't.
And they wanted to identify
those different situations.
And the evidence they
collected suggested
that if the polluters
pollute without disrupting
the habits of the community,
the community paid no attention
to the pollution.
But if the pollution
disrupted habits,
such as getting
children to school,
or preparing meals, or being
able to ride on the bus,
then the population mobilized.
The routines encouraged
people to adopt
what we are calling automatic
pilot, or automatic cognition,
to their surroundings.
But when routines
are disrupted, people
began to explore and
try to figure out
what it was in the environment
that was disrupting it.
So in these cases,
familiar routines
combined with
automatic cognition
to restrict the attention
to the pollution.
So that's a second example.
Third example, in a study
of political commitments,
Martin and Desmond found
that when citizens identify
themselves as having strong
political commitments
along a continuum from
liberal to conservative,
so if they were strong
at one end or the other
of the political spectrum,
they spent less time evaluating
the evidence about politics.
The ideological commitments
organized the world for them.
And it made it
effortless and efficient
to know how to interpret
and how to make decisions.
In a study of social
movements, the scholars
found that when movement leaders
use everyday metaphors, that is
ordinary language,
in particular ways,
they generate more
or less support.
So for example, the right
to life movement came up,
that is an
anti-abortion movement,
came up with a simple
phrase, right to life.
And that had more
salience than did choice
for those who were pro-abortion.
And so the metaphors
aligned with a whole set
of other metaphors.
So that people
thought more or less
about the process of abortion.
OK, the same thing with
faith-based labor movements.
In the 19th century,
Mark Steinberg
has written about the
ways in which the cotton
workers in England were
able to mobilize and form
a union because,
this is in the 1830s
to '50s, because they used
the already existing language
of abolition against slavery.
And they identified their work
in the cotton mills as slavery.
And by associating
themselves with slavery,
people didn't pay as much
attention to the differences
and were more likely to
support and join the unions.
More recent research
along this issue
of the metaphors, the signaling,
this is about signaling,
the metaphors that affect
deliberate or automatic
cognition, a study of the
Serbo-Croatian conflict
in the 1990s showed
that the associations
with the past that people used
affected the level of conflict.
Particular words and metaphors
generated associations
with the past.
So that people viewed
the current conflict
as a continuation of hundreds
of years of conflict,
rather than assess
the current conflict
within current conditions.
So simple metaphors
associations encourage
people to think deliberately
or to act automatically.
So finally, the last
example of these differences
between automatic and
deliberate cognition
comes from work on narrative.
So we've gone, I
just want you to see,
from routines, to
disruptive habits,
to language organizing
social movements and wars.
And now we have, from
metaphors, we go to narratives.
So researchers have
not only looked
at these routines,
metaphors, analogies,
for triggering automatic rather
than deliberate cognition,
but also at the structure,
how the metaphors are
organized into a story at
narrative and storytelling.
Some of the very
best research on this
has been done in courtrooms.
So that if witnesses
tell a story
and they leave out little links
in the sequence of action,
the audience, the
jurors, and the judges
are more likely to
fill in those ellipses
with conventional action.
That is what usually is
done in those circumstances.
And it is most often to the
disadvantage of a defendant,
because the defendant is arguing
that this was not routine.
But this was unusual.
So witnessing, in
criminal courts,
makes a difference how
complete your narrative is.
If it is not, then
people automatically
fill in with
routinized information.
In my own work, I have shown
that when a story describes
or fails to describe--
let me put it
this way, when a story fails
to describe how power is
organized, people are less
likely to resist the power
of that organization or person.
But when a story reveals
who holds power and why,
then people are more
likely to resist authority.
So a little bit
of, perhaps, what
was happening last spring
in the Middle East.
As stories circulated on
the internet about what
was happening in
different places,
in villages and towns
in Libya and in Egypt,
those stories spread.
And they told stories,
they were stories,
about what the government
was doing to whom.
And it helped to
mobilize the people.
So that's what cognitive
science is telling us
about how people make deliberate
or automatic decisions.
We have some
experimental data that
helps us to understand
how decisions
can be made specifically
about energy consumption.
So this was the articles you
read, I think, the experiments?
Right, Goldstein,
Cialdini, and Grisk--
I can't say that.
So what did they want to show?
What did they want to show?
Yeah, Veronica?
AUDIENCE: They wanted
to change the wording
that they had to say your
fellow guests are doing it.
Help your fellow guests.
SUSAN SILBEY: Why?
Why did they want to do that?
AUDIENCE: Because subliminally,
that social pressure
would motivate
them more to do it.
And there's examples
given in the other article
about how when people gave
money to the guy playing
guitar or whatever, other
people behind the guy who gave--
SUSAN SILBEY: So those are two--
those are two different norms.
Yes, those are--
looking for norms are
observed patterns of action.
That's what a norm is.
They're looking to
see if they can find
the pattern in human action.
AUDIENCE: Yes, Vivian.
So they did find a pattern.
And I think they just want to
show that this tactic isn't
being used.
Whereas, because
this is something
that we can use to
help people started
making environmentally
conscious decisions,
and it's not being used.
SUSAN SILBEY: I don't want
to be personally critical.
But they don't want
to show anything.
They want to discover something.
OK, let's talk about it in
a way that is fair to them.
They have an aspiration
to understand.
They want to
understand the basis
upon which decisions about
energy use can be affected.
OK, they want to understand
the basis of decision making.
OK, and the assumption
they start with,
the hypothesis is
that people mimic.
They do what other people do.
And they care about
whether they are a member
of one group or another.
That seems they
have an identity.
So let's walk through it.
All right, they're trying to
use, as I have on the screen,
social norms, that's patterns,
to motivate conservation.
Is it possible?
So the question
was, the first one,
would people not put
their towels for laundry
but would reuse their towels?
And the standard message was,
help save the environment.
But the message that they
offered was slightly different.
They said, you should do
this, because everybody else
is doing it.
Does that appeal to you?
Have you seen these signs?
You've never seen
these signs in hotels?
AUDIENCE: I've definitely
seen the signs, more in Europe
than over America.
But it's also not only that
other people are doing it.
I think in this case, it speaks
to anti-environmental movement
that says one towel hanging is
not going to make a difference.
So a lot of people,
their motivation
is brought down,
because they're saying,
I'm going through
all this trouble.
Nobody is around me.
I'm not making a difference.
Why am I going to keep
the self-sacrifice?
So by telling them, it's
not only the bandwagon idea.
But it's also the--
look we're actually
doing it in Europe,
and it's actually
going to go a long way.
SUSAN SILBEY: So trying to say
that each effort aggregates
to a larger effort.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN SILBEY: And that other
people are doing it, too.
So it's not just one
person's effort, right?
OK, so they got 75%
more reuse by simply
saying join your fellow guests.
So then they tried to specify,
is it just all guests?
Or could they get an
even greater result?
So in our Weberian
concepts, this
is sort of a little
bit of be like others.
Enjoy your group membership.
But it's hardly
efficiency, right?
It's not a calculation of
what would be rational action.
So then they first ask the
people who they identify with.
Do you identify with the
people who are male or female,
or are citizens of
the state, or are you
an environmentally
concerned person,
with other hotel guests, or
with guests in this room?
I have to confess I find
this an extraordinary result.
As you see, in the
bottom set, those
with who identified with the
standard environmental message
had less reuse than those where
they said people in this room
didn't reuse their towels.
They did.
I'm sorry, did
reuse their towels.
So you should be like
people in this room.
I think it's bizarre.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Well,
it's the proximity.
You don't want to be seen
as that one guy who's not
doing his part to contribute.
SUSAN SILBEY: You think
it's a smaller group.
And therefore, you'll
be more outstanding.
AUDIENCE: The
effect of you being
seen as a pariah
is more immediate,
because the small room.
SUSAN SILBEY: But you
don't know those people.
AUDIENCE: So there's
no one in this room.
SUSAN SILBEY: He's alone.
He's alone.
It's a hotel room,
not a dormitory.
AUDIENCE: I can't
really articulate.
I still think proximity has to
do something with it, the fact
that it was this room.
SUSAN SILBEY: Yeah,
obviously has something,
but I find it unpersuasive.
Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
identify themselves
with the select group
of people who are
more likely to be in that room.
SUSAN SILBEY: I
think that's right.
I think that this room--
and maybe that's what
he was getting at.
That's a smaller
group of people.
I'm more like a person
who would be in this room
than I am like 350 million
citizens or half of them, male
or female.
Or even the number of
environmentally concerned
citizen.
So people in this room
is a smaller group.
And I'm more like those who
stay in this kind of hotel room.
Yes, Matthew.
AUDIENCE: Is it saying that the
people who identify themselves
as environmentally
concerned are least
likely to recycle the towels?
SUSAN SILBEY: Than when they
offered the other identities
to choose.
AUDIENCE: I think that's the
most surprising on there.
PROFESSOR: But the
message was presumably
be environmentally responsible,
recycle, as opposed
to recycle like people
who stayed in the room.
AUDIENCE: So it's not
what they identify with.
It's what they're given.
SUSAN SILBEY: It's the message.
Oh, it's the message,
which message got a boost.
PROFESSOR: The standard
environmental message
said help save the
environment, use your towels.
SUSAN SILBEY: And this
one, and for people who--
OK, but the other one
was be like people
who were in this room.
AUDIENCE: I think
you can attribute
the discrepancy between the
standard environmental message
and the same room.
And the whole--
I think the one to the extreme
right appeals to something
that's more common among humans,
just the need or the desire
to appear more fit, or more
civilized, or more respectable,
even when nobody's
watching, as opposed to just
standard environmental
message that only
a small subset of the public
even, I guess, care about,
acknowledge.
SUSAN SILBEY: Charlotte?
AUDIENCE: Could
also be like what
you were talking about
earlier, with what you register
and what you just
kind of see something
that's there all the time.
So standard environmental
messages are everywhere.
So it's possible people just
don't really register it.
But if you see a message
that says something different
than you're used to seeing,
you may just notice it more
and respond to it
because of that.
SUSAN SILBEY: Possible,
disrupted the routine.
Rachel?
AUDIENCE: The other thing, too,
is the argument about people
that have been in that room
doing the same thing, I think
Cialdini, in his
book, or whatever,
he talks about people being
more likely to do something
if someone's watching them.
And the fact that
they're saying,
oh, people who've stayed in
this room have been doing it,
implies the hotel is
watching which guests are.
SUSAN SILBEY: Yes,
that implies they know.
Very good, so maybe that
suggested surveillance.
There was another
hand up over here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was going metnion,
all these were good points.
But also people like
to be a part of a team.
That kind of makes you feel
part of a group that's being
environmentally conscious.
SUSAN SILBEY: Yeah, I think
that's what Ovema and Everson
was saying, too.
You're all on the same.
This business of possibly their
surveillance is a new insight.
Yes, Andrew?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN SILBEY: And
so why would you
get more reuse of the
towels by saying this room?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN SILBEY: We don't have
a lot of evidence about that
is the problem.
That's the
individualist fallacy,
that there are always people
who want to be different.
But then there's people
It's a group who
wants to be different.
This search for the
unique is the problem.
PROFESSOR: Back in the '60s,
there were a lot of rebels
all together.
SUSAN SILBEY: All
wanting to be different.
That's the problem.
It's social.
It's not individual.
That's the issue.
Yes, Scott?
AUDIENCE: Somebody pointed out
earlier that someone might not
want to reuse a towel.
Because they think that
I'm only one person,
what's this going to do?
But I think if you have the
info that, oh, well, everyone
in this room is using a towel.
So that you think, oh, if
I'm the one person who's
not doing it, then, I
am making a difference,
but it's in a bad way.
So if you contribute
to it, then you're
helping make a difference.
Whereas, it's not you're
just thinking, oh, well,
one person what's
that going to do?
SUSAN SILBEY: All right, so what
other norms or incentives might
we use for energy efficient--
Oh, let me see.
Let's take the takeaway
message and then consider
some alternative.
So what this cognitive
science research
and the experimental
research shows
is that people do follow
the norms of others
with whom they feel associated,
even if that association
doesn't seem, on the
outside, terribly meaningful
as some group identity.
And in some
circumstances, individuals
follow norms of a meaningless
and unimportant identity
rather than a meaningful and
important one if the connection
is based on an uncommon
characteristic, which is maybe
helps Andrew's
point a little bit,
that this is a
smaller group, it's
an uncommon characteristic.
And it's the same as Jacob,
and Ovema, and Everson.
So I can identify
with this group.
Now, maybe if they
had some other sign,
they could have done better.
Have you got any suggestions
of what other norms
they might try to invoke?
How might you get people,
if not only in towel reuse?
How can we get people?
Yes, Sid.
AUDIENCE: Give them a
financial statistic,
nothing coming to me.
If I have like a number
or something, telling me,
how much choice A, why choice
is better than choice B.
SUSAN SILBEY: Tell
them how much?
AUDIENCE: Well, I tell them
how much they're saving.
SUSAN SILBEY: Well,
now that's interesting.
Because there was a
story in the news.
Remember the story
about there was
a story about how
the hotels were only
doing this to save money, that
they weren't, in fact, saving
energy.
And that had a negative effect.
So it has to be--
AUDIENCE: I don't mean
in this, hotel instance,
I mean when you're just
talking about energy saving.
if you can find that
discrepancy and you
can show that choice A is energy
efficient and is saving you--
SUSAN SILBEY: So you're
arguing that if you put it
into dollars,
people will behave.
AUDIENCE: I mean, for me, a
dollar amount says a lot more
than, perhaps, trying
to I guess group
me into one group or the other.
SUSAN SILBEY: That sign?
It's not too clear.
But it's how many
miles per gallon
you'll get is the car stickers.
So if you by one
car, in city driving,
you'll get 18 miles per gallon.
But on the other car, you'll
get 23 miles per gallon.
Will you buy the car
with the 23 and the 30?
Is that kind of number helpful?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
AUDIENCE: To kind of bounce
off waht he's saying,
it's a number, but
it doesn't really
tell you dollars and cents.
Oh, bigger number is better.
SUSAN SILBEY: So you
think that should
say you will save $500
this year on your gasoline,
on an average of 10,000 miles
a year or something like that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And I think
it's important that you
talking about their savings.
But that kind of
sounds like the stuff
that you were saying before, how
people act, they might have--
habitually or
traditionally and perhaps
the willingness to
change their habits
is not as great as
the willingness to--
SUSAN SILBEY: And so why
do people buy Priuses?
Yeah, Matt.
AUDIENCE: I think it's talks
to the point about style
and a need for individuality.
That people have
Priuses because they
think that they're
environmentally friendly,
but they also want--
SUSAN SILBEY: Everybody
else to think they are.
So it's not individuality.
Let's just get the terminology
clear, because it's--
because we talk about
individuals a lot.
People buy Priuses.
And what you're trying
to say is because they
want to be seen to
be environmentally?
No?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but in a way
that makes them look effortless
like they're doing it.
SUSAN SILBEY: Because
it's just routine.
I've made a commitment.
I'm a good person.
Jessica, and then Charles.
AUDIENCE: It's got to be
coupled with you go in,
and you see something that's
got off the charts mileage, MPG
mileage, and the
sales person there's
going to tell you
this is the best
investment I'm going to make.
I think if they actually
ran the numbers,
like you did in class,
in front of them,
and they told them it's never
going to break even, never
pay for itself.
I think they might not want
to still be seen [INAUDIBLE]..
SUSAN SILBEY: I didn't think the
argument was, about the Prius,
that it wouldn't be
environmentally good.
They just never get
the savings back.
But so you two are
not disagreeing.
You're offering two
different motivations.
AUDIENCE: I just think their
own economical well-being
would overpower their
want to be environmental.
SUSAN SILBEY: Well,
that's a hypothesis.
That's a hypothesis which is
challenged by all the Priuses.
Oh, you're saying
they don't know.
They don't know.
PROFESSOR: There's
also a question,
there are hybrids available
in other cars that
aren't distinctly styled.
You could buy hybrids and
various other vehicles,
as opposed to the Prius
being a hybrid Corolla,
looks like a Corolla,
it's distinctive.
You can buy hybrids in
various Ford and Chevy models
that are indistinguishable
from a distance.
SUSAN SILBEY: And that would
not serve Max's reason,
because everybody has
to know that you are--
PROFESSOR: Not many people do.
You don't buy it
for Max's reason,
because nobody can tell
you made the purchase.
And the sales are less.
SUSAN SILBEY: Jacob
and then Charlotte.
AUDIENCE: I would say
there's kind of a threshold.
Once so many Priuses
were sold, they
became a thing in advertising.
When someone thought,
I need to buy a hybrid.
They though of a Prius.
They didn't think
of other hybrids.
SUSAN SILBEY: I'll confess.
I didn't know, for a long
time, there were others.
I just saw the Priuses.
So I was one of those people who
don't recognize the ones that
are not styled differently.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: I was
just going to say
that I agree that I think
that economical position comes
into a lot of part.
Because the way that Priuses are
advertised, is their advertised
that gas is really expensive.
And this is also
environmentally friendly.
But it's a lot of--
people think that they're
going to save a lot of money.
And if you show them the
numbers, they wouldn't.
But whenever I
was getting a car,
I was considering buying
a Prius, because it's
environmentally
friendly, whatever.
But also because I
live in Oklahoma.
So I drive a lot.
And I wanted to not have to
pay a lot of money for gas.
And that was my reasoning.
And I would have never
considered running the numbers.
SUSAN SILBEY: You just
believe what they told.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
and then also, just
because when you
think of hybrid,
you think of Prius, because
of their advertising strategy.
It's not like I wasn't
wanting to buy it
just because I thought it
would make people think that I
was environmentally friendly.
It was because I thought, oh,
maybe I wanted a hybrid car.
I should get a Prius, because
that's the only one I know of.
SUSAN SILBEY: I want to get on
Max's side for just a moment.
Because I think that
people don't just
buy things because
they're efficient,
or because they're a
better economic deal.
You cannot explain
the fashion industry.
You cannot explain celebrity.
It's not about
economic efficiency.
I mean, you don't need to
have the number of sweaters
and shoes.
They don't wear out.
You don't have to change
the hems from long to short
for efficiency.
Why do people change
their clothes,
change their hairstyles?
It's not because it's
economically efficient.
There is something else.
PROFESSOR: Cadillac Escalades,
they don't carry much,
their performance is lousy,
terrible gas mileage.
SUSAN SILBEY: And why
do people buy them?
Because
AUDIENCE: Ford F150 is still the
best selling care in America.
And people like
trucks, people like
to be seen in high, big vehicles
to make them look wealthy.
And they go outdoors--
SUSAN SILBEY: It's called
status and approval.
Sid, and then Andrew.
AUDIENCE: I think has to do with
everyone's personal utility,
[INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN SILBEY: So where
did that personal--
let's get to the
basis of this lecture.
Where did that personal
utility come from?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I'm sure like
it has to do with group theory,
and which group you want
to be associated with.
But there are different groups.
And different people
might buy different things
for different reasons.
SUSAN SILBEY: And do we choose
all the groups we belong to?
Come on.
I mean, no.
You can't say, just
look around this room,
you can't say we all choose
the places, the groups we're
identified with.
Come on.
We wouldn't have the wars
we've been having if people all
chose their group identities.
Think about it.
Think what's driving the world.
And the price of oil.
Group identities, not rational
decision making, folks.
It's group identities.
Habitual, historic,
group identities
have raised the price
of oil this week.
Not rational decision making.
The stock market
went down yesterday,
and what did the analysts say?
Fear of oil reserves.
The oil reserves did
not change yesterday.
I am sorry to push back at you.
Make the rest of the argument.
Part of it's right.
But those utilities
come from someplace.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but what
I was trying to say
is that I think
everyone can reason
as to why they make a decision.
And it's like very--
yes, everyone's
utility is affected
by the groups around them.
But all I'm trying
to say is someone
will buy that Prius to
make a fashion statement.
But the utility they get out of
making that fashion statement
is worth more for
them than calculating
the savings they're going
to make and knowing that--
SUSAN SILBEY: So
you want to do--
OK, you want to do a
cost benefit analysis
and add to the benefit status
rewards and emotional rewards.
Fine, we're total
heated agreement.
OK, however, not everybody
can think through.
There are-- you have to have
the categories to think with.
That's where culture comes from.
We have cultures, and
I don't want you to--
that do not have certain
categories in them.
They just don't have them.
You're sitting in
the institution that
makes categories to think with.
But not everybody has them.
So we have to deal with the fact
that we live in an integrated
world, interconnected.
And we do not get to
choose all the time.
So Andrew had his hand.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN SILBEY: Save the dollar.
Saving the dollar
is a good idea.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN SILBEY: To
care about that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN SILBEY: To care
about little bits of money.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN SILBEY: Well,
this has been observed
about American society.
If you want, I'll
give you the source,
Thorstein Veblen was an
observer at the beginning
of the 20th century
and described
Americans preoccupation
with these kinds of things.
OK,
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE].
Dallas, Texas, you
would not do that.
Houston, Texas, you
SUSAN SILBEY: Well, see you on--
next week.
Thank you.